sakirstama's attempt to forge a new path
for labour got off to a pretty shaky
start this weekend and if anyone thought
that the party's left wingers would go
without a fight they've never met any of
the jeremy corbyn fan club in fact the
party's former leader let fly a couple
of days ago accusing the current
leadership of propping up capitalism to
be clear he thinks that's a bad thing
let's see what his brother in arms
former shadow chancellor john mcdonald
thinks uh john macdonald you described
kierstama's essay
published this week the road ahead
uh as the sermon on the mount composed
by a focus group
that's a bit disrespectful to your
leader isn't it don't worry k
here's a friend of mine he can take it
on the chin i was trying to get across
to him but we've got to go beyond
banalities we need real
real vision and policy program now and
that's why we that's what this
conference should all be about the real
concrete policies we're going to pursue
do you think that um
the labor policy offer that's being made
uh
is
familiar to you i mean i i was talking
to andre rayne this morning the attack
on private schools frankly the new deal
for working people feels pretty much
like a mcdonald deal for working people
on the new deal for working people um
angie and andy mcdonald the shadow
secretary of state within blunt
andy's been working on it for nearly
three years two and a half years at
least it's a great piece of work and
lord john hendy as well angie's fronted
that which is great so a lot of it is
building upon what we did um i think it
needs to go a bit further in terms of
pay levels not the 10 pounds i think
it's 15 pounds now we should be going
but my anxiety yesterday this is why i
i wrote a couple of pieces for the press
this weekend is that
that got drowned out by all this falling
out over the constitutional rules of our
party re we had really two good
announcements this weekend one was angel
and andy mcdonald's employment policy
but the other one was lucifer's housing
policy both terrific both in the the
trajectory of what we've been doing over
recent years but that that got
completely drowned out by the
shenanigans over our constitution really
are you going to accept the compromise
uh that has been reached on the rules is
everybody going to go okay fine i don't
think people are happy still on the
electoral college
kia pushed that unnecessarily got
defeated
then he's pushed this threshold for um
nominations from mp's the next leader
who goes on the ballot paper he got
defeated on that and got that got
amended i don't think actually we need a
change in the rule but if it goes
through to be honest we'll work with it
it won't prevent the left wing coming
forward as long as i'm concerned but i
don't think it's necessary i would
oppose it this morning if i had a vote
definitely you would oppose it yeah
do you think it's going to go through by
the way today i think it'd be touch and
go to be honest i can't predict that at
all um part of the problem is is that
we've had quite a number of clp
delegates excluded over the last few
days and again that's an issue i'm
worried about so the clp delegations
have been weakened i think they're the
strongest in opposition because they
want the members to have a full range of
candidates to choose from when there's
the next leadership election and by the
way you know i what's the rush about
changing the rules but for
nominating a leo voting for a leader
we're not gonna have a leadership
election as far as i'm aware unless
people know something i don't i'm trying
to get a sense of mcdonald of where you
really are on kierstama um
policy-wise he seems to be doing all the
things that you would have done and
would feel happy with um
maybe there's a stumble here and there
on the constitution but you should be
happy with this guy he's a democratic
elected leader he won the election 18
months ago that's the first point so you
have to respect that and i have done
the second point is on the
constitutional changes he never said a
word about that when he stood for lead
and i think that's he should have done
if he was going to change our
constitutional rules he should have said
it then and that opens him up to charges
of not being
straight with people when he stood for
there so i'm worried about that in terms
of policy we haven't heard much at all
so that's why this conference i was
urging him concentrate on policy
concentrate and get that vision across
rather than dragging us through this
mess of a rankle and argument about
faction fighting over the rules i i
don't want to keep as somebody said
yesterday wanging on about the
constitution but
do you go with the people who say that
if he's going to bring forward this kind
of thing
actually and as you say he didn't
mention it in his uh
run for leadership that he should stand
again i've said he should have gone back
to the people he should either consulted
or studied a new leadership election if
necessary but i would i said look why
don't you follow what other leaders have
done gone through a proper conscious
consensation ed miliband even had a
special conference don't try and bounce
the party like this on i want to get on
to policy and what i'm saying to you on
policy look at biden look at biden a
centrist leader which was what care
really is
but he's worked with the left and all
wings of his party and he's brought
forward a radical political program
follow that path and i think they'll
take us back into the government
do you think that the
idea of bringing forward these rule
changes
speak to something deeper the sense that
and um
maybe i'm about to compliment you the
sense that the sense that the center of
the labour party
has decided that actually the membership
has changed
quite decisively and it can't
trust the labour party's member as
membership as it currently is and
therefore it needs to
operate in a different way i think look
you've struck a raw nail there that's
quite right i think there are some
people maybe around here as well i don't
think it's kill himself but there might
be some people around here who have a
pathological fear of democracy and of
our members yet look we have a large
amount a huge membership unfortunately
it's declining at the moment because
people are getting a bit demoralized but
we have a huge membership they reflect
the wider community you know the doctors
the nurses the
people working in the public sector
lorry drivers and all the rest trust the
people that's what i'm saying to them so
don't have these shenanigans where
you're trying to restrict the role of
members in fact when kier stood for
leader he said he was going to engage
with members more and members would have
more of a role that's why people feel
this is a bit of a step backwards and
he's not he hasn't been really straight
so he's saying to him look get back on
track forget these rule changes get on
with the discussion about policy and
let's have a real discussion
the employment stuff was great lucy
powell's housing stuff was terrific
there's a lot more to go for now as well
in terms of the public schools vat that
that was one of our policies but you
know we had a wider policy which was
bringing public schools into the states
public well no we've both pre-paid we
were going to integrate them into the
public sector and that would have
eventually meant there was no need for
their existence isn't it isn't the
problem here john mcdonnell that
what kirsten wants to do
is to focus the labour party on what
labour voters think
rather than what labour activists who
have a lot of time to go to meetings and
uh argue uh the
the argue that toss over this composite
and that conversation and that what he's
trying to do with this is to move the
party over to thinking about
labour voters as opposed to labor
members there's always that issue about
a political party's membership sort of
isolating it to the wider community that
might happen if you had a small romp of
a party when you've got half a million
members that's impossible to do that
means we've got virtually a member on
every street but the key issue as well
is how do you further engage those
members in the wider community right
through community organizing all of
those issues and again the community
organizing team has been laid off and
sacked completely unnecessary so when
kia said i want to engage with members
more i want members to have more of
engagement the party we thought it was
going down the path of making sure we
broadened the membership i was aiming
for a million members we should be doing
at recruiting and recruiting all the
time but opening up our doors so that
people all have a say over the
development those policies as soon as
you start closing that down for example
restricting their ability to select the
leader or have a vote over the leader
effective vote of the leader then you're
cutting yourself out for the wider
community um would you have used the
words that angela rainer used last night
have you not heard some of my speeches
trevor it's important sometimes i'm
embarrassed they are required meeting in
my household john but i'm looking i i
would like you to share with the nation
whether you should use those terms well
we've all been there we've all been
there late at night getting very angry
about what's going on what i like about
andrew rayner is that she's human she
she may well drop herself in it just as
i've done time and time again but she
built she's human and she have human
emotions and when you get angry about
something sometimes the language that
you use might be over the top but what
she's angry about the issue we're all
angry about outlook let me just say this
trevor in my community at the moment
i've got large numbers of people who are
fearful because they're going to lose 20
pounds off their universal credit
they're going to be thrust into poverty
with children no wonder she's angry so
sometimes your language gets ahead of
you but
deep down she's expressing the anger
that many of us feel so everybody now
gets a free pass to say what they like
about other people
because they get because they're a bit
you know they're little bit emotional no
we have to be late at night no we have
to be disciplined and all of us have to
bear that in mind we need to bring
people with us around turn them off but
we're expressing human emotion here and
sometimes you don't get the language
right and some instances though actually
people forgive you for that because they
know you're actually your intentions are
good all right well
a theme this morning has been civility
and respect and you've been
extremely respectful of of your leader
uh whatever your private fittings are
the new leader of unite sharon graham
announced that she wouldn't be coming to
conference even though it's her first
opportunity to demonstrate support for
sakir stama
a bit rude or not no not really i've
known shannon i've worked with shannon
over the years she's been involved in
some of the organization and disputes in
my constituency at heathrow airport for
example she's been brilliant
her job yeah but how hard could it be to
turn up for the leader's speech she's
got about 16 disputes going at the
moment her job is at the moment as she
sees it is to concentrate on her members
who are struggling in this environment
in this economic climate so i can
understand why she puts that as a
priority but she'll be engaged it's just
look again what sharon has done
you're genuinely saying that coming down
to brighton for wednesday afternoon is
going to make the difference in any of
those 16 disputes i don't think it makes
sense this is a signal isn't it no i
don't think it makes any difference to
here whether individually i'm not saying
it makes a difference what i'm saying is
the
union leaders
who are big figures in their own right
tend and historically have paid respect
to the leader of the labour party
and they turn up to his speech
you're not with the you're not with the
game what sharon is about no listen that
what sharon is about is saying i'm with
trade union general secretary but i'm a
member of a team her team is down here
as a delegation she has confidence in
them she's no longer boss politics i
have to order everything around what
she's doing is getting on with her job
as she sees it the priority and the
industrial struggles that her workers
are having their living stones their
fight to keep their jobs and to fight to
keep that protect their families that's
what she's concentrated on she said i've
got a good team in the delegation there
they'll manage all the decisions that
have taken place it's a democratic union
the positions have been taken by the
union number a number of issues that
delegation will vote calling it's
democracy
john mcdonnell thank you very much